this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Applause]
[Music]
live from the head live from
headquarters of ramsey solutions
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studio this
is the ramsey show where america hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life
and your money i'm christy wright and
joining me today is my good friend
ken coleman he's a number one
best-selling author host of the ken
coleman show
and career expert and this is exciting
ken because we were just talking before
we went live that you and i have not
hosted together in a really long time a
long time
but what i love about this hour that we
get to host together is you and i
are kindred spirits when it comes to
helping people
find their purpose yes you do it in the
career space i do it in the business
space
and we come together a lot like entre
leadership events and that type of thing
so
america if you're listening right now
and you have a question
about your purpose your career
a job change maybe some opportunities
you have in front of you
if you're looking for what's next for
you trying to discern what the best
decision is
maybe you've got an itch to do something
new and you're not sure if that new
thing is a business
or a career move maybe you are
in a life transition your kids just went
to school or
they're going off to school for the
first time maybe you're an empty nester
and you're looking for hey what's next
for me
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five and we are here answering
your calls always about money
but today is special because ken and i
are uh experts in the career and
business space and we would love to help
you figure out what your purpose is
and and if you're just struggling you
got all these dreams and everything
you're talking about
you're just like how do i balance it all
how do i ca how do i deal with all the
spinning plates
now i'm the professional plate spinner
who doesn't do it well
christy could help you and i can
commiserate with you
the new book available for pre-sale take
back your time the guilt-free guide to
life balance oh we could take those
questions as well
you might just tease a little bit of the
content in your answers yes yes
let me do this okay let's talk about
let's here we go where are the guys in
the back can we zoom in
can we zoom look at this cover this is
gorgeous there it is it's always on the
bottom of the screen
look at you right there shoes off very
happy
but i know how frenetic your life
actually is because i know you're
i know you're hubs and i know you're
awesome two boys and that little
princess
yeah you don't always look like this no
i feel like
that is a large scenario that made me
look like that no you look fat but my
point is
this is a balanced rested but you know
how to get there
okay so let's talk about it because
actually i think that that's uh
it's such a pain point for people can
men women kids no kids doesn't matter
everyone struggles with it in different
ways and you make a good point i've got
you know i'm in the season of little
littles you've got three kids but
they're a little older than mine i'm in
in the trenches and yours is insanity
right yeah and i started seminary three
weeks ago which is like
oh sure we'll just just a small just a
small thing so i'm i'm actually living
this out
while teaching it but i wanted to bring
up something for you
because i mentioned this before we went
live and i didn't even know if you knew
this but i talk about you in this book
is it good do you talk about me it is
good it is good but i want to set it up
because
here's why the thesis of the whole book
is life balance isn't doing everything
for an equal amount of time
no it's about doing the right things at
the right time
very well so so you've heard me talk
about this at summit but one of the
things that gets in the way
of our ability to be balanced and do the
right things the right time
is we do the wrong things and so when i
walk people through this
path and building a schedule and so on
and actually make some notes in there if
when you're creating
your ideal schedule you're putting those
things that we identified were important
to you on your calendar
you realize you're putting something on
your calendar
that you do not love is not important
does not bring you joy does not give you
purpose
like let's say your job yeah and you
spend 40 hours a week at this thing you
hate
you're never gonna feel balanced because
it doesn't matter if you perfectly
micro manage your calendar if you spend
a large portion of your time
on something you hate of course you're
not going to feel balanced so talk about
what you see
when you're coaching people and helping
people how their career choice how their
job
affects so many other areas of their
life because it does
it does so let's take that question and
let's just add one other little nuance
it doesn't have to be a job that you
hate
but it also could be a job it's just
kind of
it's kind of a it's a j-o-b you don't
hate it
but you have no juice for it and to
answer your question chrissy here's what
happens
when you spend let's just say minimum 40
hours a week
but even in a part-time job that you
don't love the work and the work itself
doesn't create a result
that fires your heart up so that's
passion and mission when you don't have
that here's what happens
you can't feel anything over time you
become a zombie
you don't have any feeling your heart is
kind of like sleepwalking
you're just like oh this is something
i've got to do and this is why
sunday nights are full of depression and
anxiety
that's why monday morning is so
difficult
for people to get out of bed so to
answer your question
yeah that you don't feel much of
anything and you won't feel like you're
doing
much of anything which is not true
you're still
valuable it may not be a job that you
love it may not be a job
um that you even like but you're still
doing something and you matter but
here's what happens when we don't see
significant
significance in our work christy what
happens is the slippery slope is
my job doesn't matter to me that's where
it starts
then it goes into huh maybe i don't
matter
that's dangerous whoa yeah and the
reality is you do matter
whether you're working on purpose or not
but that is absolutely a great question
and and listen we know this
that uh men specifically
uh but certainly women too but men big
time
put so much self-worth into your work
and where's that coming from is that
misguided no
somewhere along the line every human
being christie asked the question
what should i do with my life nobody has
to teach us that just like we don't have
to teach toddlers to say
no it just comes right out that's right
you and i believe
that's why you're in seminary yeah
you're in seminary to dive deeper on
this
yeah you and i believe that genesis
chapter 2 makes it pretty clear that the
creator of the universe
wants us to work so i say on the ken
coleman show you were created
to contribute yeah if we take the word
work out of that sentence you were
created to work
huh if i tell you we're created to
contribute people go
that's true and so there is purpose in
your work there's purpose in your
business
so so speak to the person that does not
believe
that um that work could matter and what
i mean by that is they've just they've
worked at j.o.b so long
it's hard for them to believe that
something more is possible like i
thought this is what it is this is just
this is what you do
speak into some hope into them that you
could actually go to work and get
excited on monday and love what you do
like you and i do by the way
i would just take that person i would
say at some point in your life whether
as a student
a high school or a college kid or maybe
in one job
one afternoon you did a task that you
really enjoyed yeah surely i hope i hope
well i know that's true
even if they've never experienced that
at work i can tell you this yeah there
was a subject matter in school
yeah something that made them light up
there was an intrinsic motivation
there and so that's the idea behind
mission when i say results that matter
that's mission that comes from an
intrinsic i
i do it because i want to and and the
idea is that there is work that we all
look forward to when you and i get a
chance to broadcast or speak or write
we look forward to it there's high
emotion
in anticipation and then in the middle
of it then there's high devotion
when we don't feel good when we're
frustrated
we keep doing it we suffer for it
that's passion don't tell me that that
doesn't exist for you it's not true
if that if you're saying that you just
haven't tasted it yet
so good ken coleman and i am christy
wright we're taking your calls triple
eight
eight two five five two two about career
business life and of course always money
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm christy wright joining me today is
best-selling author and my good friend
ken coleman he is also in case you
didn't know a career expert
he has a best-selling book called the
proximity principle
and we are celebrating my new book uh in
pre-sale this week which is called take
back your time the guilt-free guide to
life balance so we are here for you
america
to answer your calls whether it's about
career decisions
starting a side business time management
and as always
money give us a call triple eight eight
two five
two and we're gonna go ahead and go to
baltimore
with cindy hey cindy how are you
hi i'm doing well how are you good how
can ken and i help today
so i'm sort of talking to my fiance he
has an
opportunity a job opportunity in
california we currently
live in maryland and we just bought a
house a few months ago
so it's a pretty big decision and i'm
just sort of looking for some advice
i'm not sure if financially it makes
sense i can work online and keep my job
um he'll be making maybe a few thousand
more but
not as comparable as the cost of living
from maryland to california
so i guess i'm just looking for some
advice
well let's start with where is he
leaning on this mike
it feels like he's leaning toward
wanting to do it is that true or false
i think that's true yeah yeah so why
it's clearly not the two thousand
dollars that's not it's money
the current money certainly is not the
motivator what's the motivator for this
move
so i think he thinks it'll be more
fulfilling that job because right now
he's in the air force and he works for
you know he
does his job but he has an opportunity
where he can stay in and go over there
and
teach what he does and i think he would
find that
a little more fulfilling than what he
currently does okay
so he's not on the phone calling us
you are yeah and i know you said you
want our advice and well christy and i
never shy up for giving advice
but i think there's something deeper
here is it truly the money thing because
hey we just bought a house which
you know you guys aren't even married
yet what's the is there an actual date
on the calendar
and then is he as concerned about the
cost of living as you
i mean there's let's go deeper here i
want to know
where you two aren't on the same page
but first when are we getting married
may 6th of next year we've already put
the deposit down on the venue
we're doing tasting with the caterer
next week okay what's coming together is
that in baltimore
um actually in virginia and like a
little winery
and how long ago did you buy the house
in may okay so would you really read
that
yeah no i get it okay so where are we
where are we not on the same page lay it
out for christy and i please
okay i think i really like living in a
house we have a backyard we have a dog
we just let them out
it's fun to hang out and this is where
my family is
his family is on the west coast in
california utah and arizona
so i think i would miss being near my
family
as well as sort of the quality of
having all in the backyard whereas over
there we could afford an apartment
yep okay so i'ma let christie weigh in
in a second i'm going to tell you real
quick because
it's pretty simple to me okay
this is not a professional decision
the professional decision is easy
if it were a professional decision i
would say yep he needs to do it
because he absolutely has found
something that i think he's pretty
passionate about the way he described it
he wants to go out there and teach he
sees an opportunity for a ladder as well
not just a 2 000 bump but ultimately a
ladder but really to do the work that he
really loves to do and he can stay in
the service
but do something he really enjoys the
professional answer is really easy
this is a relational issue here's the
deal his family's on the west coast
and this is an opportunity for him to
pursue work that he loves
ding ding ding ding ding for him your
family's still in baltimore or wherever
you are on the east coast
and you just bought this house and it's
got a nice backyard and all the things
okay it's a nest for you you've already
fallen in love with this nest
so this is a relationship issue i do not
have a direct answer i'll tell you that
i think you two have got to come
together
and we've got to sit down and go what's
going on here where
what's the big picture we're about to
get married in may that means
we come together and each of us have our
own dreams and desires and they've got
to come together
and only in relationship and commitment
and and then somebody's sacrificing at
different times
and you two've got to figure this out
this is a sit down and it's a big
picture situation i'm not gonna tell you
what you should do
because i can't christy question uh
follow up there cindy do you all um
are how far is your family
my family's 20 minutes away okay are
y'all planning to have kids have you all
talked about that
yeah we have we were thinking maybe like
a year after getting married
okay ken is absolutely right that this
is a relationship
uh question because the there are
implications a domino effect down the
line for example if you're the one that
has an online
job and then you take care of these kids
in the future than to have your
mom or dad close by like there's such a
ripple effect
that will affect you that you guys need
to talk through all of those scenarios
but here's what i like to do cindy i
don't like either or
situations where i feel like i have two
not great options or two options that
nobody feels 100
on i like to come up with as many
options as possible and i would just
challenge you
and your spouse to look for something
locally that he can do
that gives him more purpose and
fulfillment because it doesn't the only
place that he can do something with more
purpose is not california that's right
there's ways for him to do what he wants
to do
closer to where you are now staying in
the home you just bought close to your
family
especially should you have kids in the
future and you want to stay there but
cindy i want you to stay on the line
because we have an awesome
live stream event tonight called money
and marriage
with dr john delony and our good friend
rachel cruz and they are
literally talking about these two things
they're talking about money
and marriage and that is what you're
calling in for cindy so stay on the line
kelly will get you a ticket
you and your spouse our fiance watch
this together and i bet that will give
you such great
jumping off points for conversations
around how to talk about this big
decision
that you have great uh great question
thanks for calling all right we're going
to go to logan utah with aubry hey
aubrey how's it going
good how are you guys good how can ken
and i help today
so my husband is just getting out of
school and we
are we don't have any debt and we're on
3b basically
and i'm trying to i want to
start a side job or business
talk right into your phone so we can
hear you aubrey i'm sorry
i want to start a site job or business
to try and
speed up the process for saving up for
the house
um but we have two young children and
i'm concerned about
the balance of taking care of the kids
but still trying financially what's the
business
so i want to get into being a financial
coach
oh with you guys take the ramsey class
cool
okay um what are the ages of your kids
uh two and a half in seven months oh
little bitty ones okay
oh well aubry i think that's awesome um
you definitely can
start a side business from home whether
that's being a financial coach or
otherwise the thing that you
need to think through if you are not
putting your kids in any kind of you
know preschool or child care that type
of thing at this stage
is how can you accommodate their nap
times their rhythms their schedule where
you work on the business during those
times
and i know it's not perfect and ideal
but if you set some goals around that
you say okay
i'm gonna you know wake up at this time
work on it these hours or work on it
during nap time or after they go to bed
then you can carve out some hours in a
week to work on it and set some goals
around that obviously if you decide to
go the
financial coach route there's going to
be some training certification that goes
with that as well but i'll tell you this
is uh this
challenge of balancing all the things
you want to do
is exactly why i wrote my new book take
back your time the guilt-free guide to
life balance because
it's not bad to have so many interests
it's just that we need to decide
what is right right now and what's right
right now for you
might be just taking care of those kids
and what's right right now might be
starting a business but only you can
figure that out when you start digging
into
what your top priorities are so if
you'll stay on the line again i will
have kelly get you a pre-order copy of
the book it will ship to you whenever
it is actually available on september
14th
and you'll have a copy of my new book
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance
to help you discern what is right for
you
right now this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
i'm christy wright and joining me today
is ken coleman number one best-selling
author host of the ken coleman show and
the ken coleman show is available every
weekday on siriusxm
your local radio station and wherever
you listen to podcasts
i also have a show the christy wright
show every tuesday
on youtube and again wherever you listen
to podcasts here at ramsey solutions we
are all about
giving you life transformative
tips and information to bring you hope
to help you
get control of your money pursue your
purpose
take control of your time and just have
a better
life ken and i are uh answering your
questions today triple eight eight two
five
five two two five we are here for you
so if you have a question about your
career a job change
a side business small business
leadership
time management and of course always
money and it's amazing how money affects
all of those things and time does as
well
in fact give us a call that's triple
eight eight two five
five two two five and we will take your
call we're gonna go to charlotte north
carolina
with tom hey tom how are you
hey christy hold on let me get you off
the speaker okay
okay there we go um
so i called him about a month and a half
ago
and uh ken i don't know if you remember
i'm uh
visually impaired and uh getting ready
to make a move to
ohio and
so um
[Music]
i had when you and i talked i talked
about
taking some business courses and
you told me i needed to get a lot
clearer
so in the process of that i'm working
with a real estate agent in the area
who i'm not
i don't feel understands my needs as a
visually impaired person
um my car payment has been and always
will be zero dollars a month
um since i don't know since i don't own
a car
oh okay um right that's due to being
visually impaired you wouldn't want me
on the road no so tom tom
refresh me really quick uh how bad is
the visual impairment
i mean i can see that enough to get from
point a to point b but
me and you wouldn't want me on the road
no i get that i'm talking about if
you're if you're thinking you're talking
to a real estate agent who doesn't
understand your needs are
since i sent you back to get more clear
on what you really want to do you're
looking into real estate is that what
i'm hearing
yes sir that is correct so and wanting
to sell homes
correct list all right how would your
visual
impairment let's just say that that
stacey and i
uh signed you up and said hey we want to
list our house would you how would your
visual impairment affect your ability to
list our house sell our house show the
house
you know the whole deal other than that
i can't drive i don't know of any way
that it would
okay so what's the question and what
does it have to do with this
real estate agent how do i how
well they uh because i'm visually
impaired
location has a deeper meaning in that
i need to be where things are walkable
and that i have access to bus
transportation
okay so you're calling us you're calling
us from charlotte north carolina where
there's public transportation
and the city of charlotte you know i'm
guessing pretty hot and popping like
nashville and atlanta true or false
that would be true okay so hit christy
and i what's the question how can we
help
where do i where would i begin of course
i need to get licensed and all that
good stuff just you just answered your
own question so you need to get license
all right so let's go
actually get qualified if tom if
and again i know it was a month and a
half ago but i talked to a lot of people
if you really feel like real estate is
in that sweet spot where you've got the
talent for it
you really enjoy the work this is a
people driven
type of work this is all communication
there's details and research and all
that
and then the result of that work is
obviously we're talking about
fulfilling people's dreams comfort
safety all the things that come with a
home purchase
if this is in fact in your sweet spot
then it's about
really talking to a couple more real
estate agents i know you've had not had
a good experience with this one you
called us about
but verifying clarifying and verifying
yep
this is i know everything that goes into
this i absolutely want to do this
if in fact that's where we stand and i'm
assuming that's the case since you've
listened to my show and you've called me
before
then you've got to go get qualified and
so you've got to get the licensing
and then while you're doing that you
want to make the connection to where you
get with a good broker somebody who
understands your limitations
but does not see limitations for you
in your career and your ability to self
that's what we're talking about here if
you do that
i mean at the end of the day there's
nobody stopping you from being
successful in real estate other than you
understood i want to give you one thing
tom to do i want to give you one thing
to jump in and add to what ken said
because he's exactly right but i want to
give you one thing to do
as a part of it like when he was talking
about getting clear assuming you're
clear but
but let's just take one more step i'd
love to insert there
so i don't know if you're like this time
but sometimes i'll have ideas of things
i want to do
and and what i think it's going to be
and what it actually is or two different
things
so i would just challenge you to and ken
talks about this a lot in his book
proximity principle but
get connected with agents in your area
and volunteer to shadow them
interview them intern with them be there
be their admin help just be in their
presence
and volunteer to do anything that you
can because here's what that's going to
do
it's going to give you a taste of the
real day-to-day
not in theory what you think this job is
and i think in your situation being
visually impaired
that will be that much more important
because there may be some aspect of this
day-to-day that is actually more
difficult for you
or less enjoyable for you than you think
it's going to be
it will just help you get that extra
layer of clarity before you go get
licensed and spend that money and make
that commitment
so i would just challenge you make some
connections uh ken like can we send him
your book
can you give him your proximity yeah
hang on the line we'll get it to you
i mean he's really begun that step which
is huge and and he's got to just that
clarify and verify is exactly what
you're just talking about
where we we we've run this thing the the
day in day out the good parts the bad
parts we run it through our head that's
the logic
that's the clarify and then our heart is
going to verify it's either going to be
those
you know the classic x's on uh on family
feud
or it's going to go ding ding ding and
so let the brain do what it's supposed
to do which is
logically process information and let
the heart do what it's supposed to do to
verify
yeah if this is like a tuning fork going
off in your chest tom
then we do it but i'm going to challenge
you one other thing here i heard
the voice of doubt all over you and many
times when we get to a place where we go
okay i know i want to do this thing
but this is a whole new thing christy it
is very natural
to feel fear and doubt and fear and
doubt protect us sometimes
but many times they'll lie to us and
hold us back and the very thing well
i've got to be in an area
where i can walk and show homes or at
least get transportation and again
sure but that's not going to limit you
in charlotte north carolina it's many
times
right on the precipice of stepping out
folks your head will try to talk you out
of it by coming with all the reasons why
it might be difficult
i got news for you it's going to be
difficult
you don't need to manufacture reasons
anytime we start and do something
there's going to be difficulties and i
can promise you this is going to be
failure on the way to success so let's
not overthink this
let the heart guide and decide and then
move
and do it it's so interesting too
because i think that sometimes ken and i
i had this example in college i remember
in college i've told the story before
but
i thought i wanted to be an event
planner because i was like i like
parties i like to celebrate i'm good at
you know i'm good at hosting things and
so i told my mom that i was like yeah i
think that's what i want to do i had a
business degree but i was like i think i
want to
like be an event planner and my mom said
which was very wise at the time she said
christy i want you to think about what
that really is
yeah you're thinking i party for work
that sounds awesome
i plan balloon arches that's the party's
your middle name sounds fantastic
sure and she said okay the reality of
that
career path is nights and weekends and
holidays because that's when people have
parties
that one statement help me
reframe do i really want to do this
because sometimes we think this is what
it's going to be and real estate is just
like that it is
showings on evening showings on weekends
depending on you know tom's family or
other responsibilities so for anybody
listening
if you want to do something ask people
doing it
you'll get the real story of the day to
day the good the bad the ugly and then
you can decide with more clarity
and more accuracy if you still want to
pursue that path if you do
cool if you don't we just saved you from
spending a lot of money and time going
down a path that you actually didn't
want to end up going down
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm christy wright and joining me for
one more segment today is
ken coleman and we're taking your calls
about life money
career business purpose whatever you
want to talk about
we are here for you triple eight eight
two five five
two two five and we're going to go to la
with aaron hey aaron how's it going
hey good morning everybody good morning
ken thank you so much for having me on
sure how's it going what can we do
man i am in a pickle
let's have it i moved from nashville
not too far from the studio actually to
la i'm moving in with my mother-in-law
with my beautiful bride and my newborn
and uh
since having our son i have had a hard
time finding work-life balance it is
so uh suffocating being being out 12
hours a day and then
obviously helping out with the newborn
when i can but my question to you is how
do you
as you go through baby steps too which
we're currently doing
how do you have shifts between the
mindset of
gazelle mentality and working your
facebook which my wife and i have no
problem doing versus
making sure you don't burn out and have
a quality of life that it's impossible
to do
seems like it's impossible to do both
yeah i i love this question aaron and i
love how you asked it because
i think a lot of people feel um
unnecessary pressure to have this
perfect balance and ken and i were just
talking about this a little bit ago
we have this idea that life balance is a
50 50 split
which is not realistic or desirable we
think it's doing everything for an equal
amount of time
and that's not realistic either so
really the what i like to tell people
and teach people and i want to walk you
through this aaron
is that life balance is not doing
everything for an equal amount of time
it's about doing the right things at the
right time and only you can decide what
those right things are
now because you have a newborn that
obviously is a
major factor in how you feel right now
one of the things i actually lay out in
my book aaron is
that sometimes we have feelings that
make us feel like our whole life is out
of whack but it's just a feeling for
example being tired
sometimes when you're tired you feel
like your whole world is upside down
and you get eight hours of sleep you're
like okay i am okay
it's hard to accurately assess how
you're doing or how
you're what you need to do in your life
when you're tired or when you're
stressed or when you're overwhelmed and
i'll walk through those
in my book but in your specific instance
what i think would be really helpful for
you to do
is to sit down with your spouse and
identify what are your top priorities in
this season
i can probably guess some of them when
you said you're on baby step two your
gazelle intense that's going to be a top
priority for you
taking care of your newborn what that
looks like for you or for her or who's
who's
taking the majority of the
responsibilities but when you put on
paper
what your top priorities are it gives
you permission to say no to everything
else
it gives you permission to say you know
what maybe i'm not working out maybe i'm
not seeing my friends maybe my house is
not clean
because i'm in a season of a newborn and
i'm gazelle intense maybe i'm not going
out and spending money out here or doing
this
it's not about doing everything for an
equal amount of time it's about doing
the right things the right time what's
right for you right now
when you figure out what that is it
allows you to say no to everything that
it's not
and it also helps you shake the guilt
that comes from oh i'm failing oh i'm
failing
you're not failing you just need to ask
yourself what's right right now
i'm i'm in a similar uh seat with you
aaron with uh work i'm going into a very
busy work season i'm launching this book
i'm going to be on the road i'm going to
be traveling
if you looked at my life as this one
snapshot oh that's very out of balance
yeah if if
if your version of balance is everything
for an equal amount of time but if
but if it's doing the right things at
the right time then i am balanced and
you are too so i just want to encourage
you to sit down with your spouse
write down what are your top three to
five priorities
three to five not 35 three to five in
order of importance
and then you make decisions on how you
spend your time according to that but
when you're tired
because you will be because you have a
newborn and you're working your tail off
at this job and to to pay off your debt
just know
tired this is a season now you don't
need to be tired
for five years but if you're tired in
this season it doesn't mean your whole
world's out of balance it just means
what you're doing right now is in a
tiring season does that make sense
aaron absolutely i mean you're preaching
to the car yeah erin why are you working
12 hours
why are you working so hard
there's a reason you're gazelle intense
what's the what's the other side of this
christie's right when you do that
priority exercise
you gotta allow your heart to realize
what's really going on your brain's
telling you you're exhausted she's
absolutely right you're going to get
bone
tired you're going to get frustrated
your heart's going to miss the little
one when you're working that extra shift
when christy tells you to work those
priorities she's leading your heart back
to the top of this list here where the
heart goes
okay i'm doing this i'm working 12 hours
because of this because of this because
of this
it's a desired future those priorities
are the why do you hear what i'm saying
aaron
you guys are preaching to the choir i
mean
my family is my everything seeing my son
grow up
seeing him one hour a day yeah i know
feeling like he's doubling in weight
every second
yeah it's incredible it's a gift and
it's the worst feeling in the world i'm
not having him close by and not being
with family but
i hear you what do you do here do it for
let me share something with you real
quick aaron
so you know your son has no clue he has
no concept of time right now that's the
great news about this
that's a super practical thing this is
actually the best time for you to work
your tail off yeah it's not going to
change how your heart feels so
i don't want to be glib and i don't want
anybody honest to think well ken you're
simple
no no i'm saying your heart's still
going to hurt
but if you realize your kid's not going
to resent you and those tears that
you're crying for your son man that's
why you're doing this and he doesn't
know
he has no difference but he doesn't know
that here between one minute and 10
minutes
what do you do aaron what's your job so
so
i'm currently just i've hopped around
over the since coveted with different
sales jobs
um which is not what i'll be doing
forever it's not my passion in life but
right now i'm doing solar in california
because it's a great market and it's a
growing company so
it makes a lot of sense for the for the
time being how much longer until you're
um
debt free um so it looks like based on
the trend
we've got about another 30 000 left in
my
student loan so we'll be should be done
in five five or six months
five or six months aaron dude five or
six months come on man five or six
months
five or six months you you can do this
listen you are not a bad dad no you are
doing a
great job you're doing what's right
right now you are busting it to get out
of debt for your family for
your son for your future and you're
going to have some more freedom options
flexibility and oh by the way time and
money
when you're on the other side of this
you're doing great
you're doing so much better than you
think you are i
i i'm actually really really really
proud of you
you're doing the right things right now
and so many other people are making
excuses sitting on their hands and
and sitting around complaining and
you're not
you're out there doing what's best for
your family
i i i'm actually really proud of you i
know you call in feeling like you're
failing yeah i i disagree
i think you're doing a great job ken i
think i think you and i
you know yours are a little bit older
now older than mine but even carter
who's six
it's harder to leave him now than than
when he was a newborn for sure because
he didn't know
yeah and it that's but it doesn't take
away that no the pain's still there
the pain is still there we're trying to
deal with the guilt yes and if you can
remind yourself like
for example i was in california actually
launching business boutique for pre-sale
on january 31st 2017
and that is carter's second birthday and
i remember sitting backstage in the
green
room with my head my mic on tears
streaming down my face that i wasn't
there at his second birthday now did i
celebrate his birthday and we had a
party the weekend before
yes absolutely does he remember that day
no does that mean i'm a bad mom
no he knows how much you love him and a
boy wants for nothing when it comes to
love i mean it's
but as a parent you still feel that goal
but i think it's so
good to remind yourself just like you
said ken the why
now if you're if someone's listening
right now and you're just a workaholic
and you've been a workaholic for two
decades and you don't know your kids
names we're not talking to you yeah
you got your party's probably mixed up
by the way when i asked aaron
why he works 12 hours a day and he was
quiet you and i have done this long
enough to know
he wasn't stumped he was trying not to
cry yes and then he started crying and
so
i want to point out that there are other
people that are in the journey right now
they're in the middle
of of the debt snowball or maybe they're
early on in the debt snowball
or maybe they're towards the end of it
and they just
feel like they can't go another
60-hour week or a 12-hour shift
if your why is re-established
you got to know why i'm going so hard
and when she can reestablish and
aaron we got back to his heart right
there he's got this
five six months gonna go like yesterday
good
stuff well done well done erin well i
want to thank my co-hosts for this hour
ken coleman
i want to thank producer james charles
associate producer kelly daniel
and you america for joining us this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money i'm christy wright i am
an author
of business boutique and author of the
new book take back your time
that we are celebrating today and
joining me today for the next
two hours is my good friend dr john
deloney host of the dr john daloni show
and also
author of redefining anxiety so we are
here to take your calls
about anything you want to talk about
money
life relationships your marriage
time management hey marriage friends
speaking of
marriage and money tonight you're the
best at
how are you feeling about it you were
just awesome it's gonna be so fun man
anytime you can hang out with rachel and
all that crew it's a blast well not only
that but like
i can't tell you how many people i have
and you just hear this in conversation
it's so normal
to complain about something you struggle
with in your marriage but then we don't
do anything to fix it
really and tonight is such an
opportunity for people to come together
i just talked to someone in the last
hour and it was literally a marriage
question
and we said hey we're gonna give you a
ticket to this event tonight you
and it was her fiance come together
watch this
live stream event and it will give you
conversation starters
for maybe some of the things that you're
struggling with
hey thank you for transitioning to that
pitch that was really good that was
awesome very natural
and let me ask you this question
so you deal with people you've had for
years you've coached people trying to
start businesses they got an idea but
they just won't do it
and one of the things that i hear you
say a lot is you never just go
just start just get in there i wonder if
and i've never had this conversation
with you i wonder if
there is a similar train of thought as
to why people know their marriage isn't
great
they know things are struggling they
don't i don't feel right but i'm just
not going to do anything about it and
you look up and it's three years later
it's five years later seven years later
i wonder if there's a similar similar
trajectory there why do people tell you
at the end of the day they don't start
that business they don't
try that side hustle why do they not do
those things
i think with i think with business and
my my hunches
it's much more fear based i'm scared of
putting myself out there whereas in
marriage at least uh you know anything
that matt and i have if we've gone
through tough seasons
it is by degrees it's so gradual i mean
when you're
you know a newlywed everything's
exciting and new and easy and then
and then it gets hard and you have kids
and it gets harder and you're tired and
grouchy it's so
incremental that things might get hard
and i think that
it almost happens so gradually a lot of
times that
um you don't even notice it's happening
and then you look up one day
and you just accept it as the new normal
like well this is how we interact or
this is as good
as it gets i remember um when matt and i
were newlyweds
we were in this small group at church
and someone had recommended someone
older had
marketed him in this marriage book it
was like a christian faith-based
marriage book and
and we read it and it's like five-star
reviews it's just like a hugely
successful book
and we didn't relate at all because it
was literally talking to people that
like
don't like each other like we love each
other and it will always be this way
never talk we will never think about
each other that that's so mean
and then it's like then it's like you
know three in the morning and your child
has like peed in the bed and you're like
ah
you know you're screaming at each other
and you're like this this is not who i
want to be
so i think it just happened so gradually
um and then you start to
like kind of accept it as normal but
what i what i love about stuff like what
you guys are doing tonight
or or really successful marriage books
anything like that a podcast wherever
you get help
is that when you have an outside
perspective it can literally
breathe new life into your relationship
there's something about that social
norming where you realize i'm not crazy
yeah or we're not broken or we're not we
may just
be dysfunctioning but we're not forever
stuck on this trajectory
yeah here's the goal for tonight i'm
gonna say some things rachel's gonna say
some things that i
know one of you two on that couch is
thinking
i'm gonna say it there's me everybody's
gonna be elbowing each other rachel's
gonna put it out we're gonna put it into
the universe
and we're gonna tee it up for you and
all you it's like a giant
red ball on a t all you gotta do is just
hit it right and
that's the goal right how can we help
facilitate folks to look at each other
and be like
can we just i mean he said it let's just
try it right we're
we're going to be there well another
thing i would say is um
if you attend the event tonight if
you're if you're listening
i really want to go but i'm scared my
spouse want to go
it doesn't mean your marriage is broken
it doesn't even mean something's wrong
it's like this can be a proactive
hey this would be cool to like you know
get other ideas and advice
i know some people feel like um like
counseling for example it's like oh you
must be like something's wrong with you
if you go to counseling it's like you
could go proactively
you should so i i remember i had a grad
school counselor and she said the shame
of counseling
the shame of an event like this is
people only go when they're in crisis
she said it's like waiting till you have
the flu
to go to the gym and start your new
workout program she said if people would
look at each other and say
we are killing it right now we could
actually go
meet with a therapist and or a coach or
whoever
and learn some skills that we can
actually hear we're not in crisis we can
practice and laugh through things or be
curious about things instead of being
angry whatever
and we could actually be in a helpful
place so if you are struggling or if you
are
rocking it man tonight in his place it's
hilarious rachel's funny and
we'll have a blast but what we're
talking about new things all this is new
talk about new stuff we talk about sex
we're going to talk about relationship
we're going to get into it because
people keep asking about it
right and we can't avoid it you're going
to talk about the things that they deal
with that they don't want to talk about
don't know how to talk about it
going back you said it's gradual i'll
tell you for me like when you said
people are scared to put themselves out
there
i do this for a living and i've found
myself in different seasons
sheila and i will celebrate 19 years the
next week and their seasons
i i just scared to say it yeah so i just
don't
right right and i don't know where this
fear comes from there's moments i've had
to remind myself over the last almost 20
years
she said in front of all of our friends
and family she wasn't gonna leave
so i have to say this right but i mean
it's this i gotta i gotta
build myself up for it and how can we
that's tonight is we're gonna take all
the air out of that right
uh speak facilitated i've got i've got a
feeling uh
about something and you tell me if i'm
right or wrong on this i feel like
counseling or and or events like what
we're talking about tonight
for older generations baby boomers
older generations for them it's that
much more of like this is a bad
thing my generation i feel like it's
much more open to counseling to
self-help
to personal development podcast books
events that type of thing
have you seen that where like maybe some
people that have been married a long
time they're
that much less likely to attend an event
like this because it means you're broken
it means like something's wrong with you
or is that just am i off basically no
you're you're 100
in and almost more i think now people
are starting to get the message you're
not broken it's not just for crazies or
whatever that means
but they also i i don't have the energy
or the capacity i don't i feel like i'm
too exhausted to even think about doing
something different
besides it's her fault or it's his fault
i'm not right can we go so you can fix
my spouse
that's how they all right like he needs
to hear this she needs to hear this and
what i love to remind people is having
sore knees
having 45 pounds that you know i've
gotta
just it's hard having a hard
conversation with your spouse because
y'all been on a hard trajectory
just turning the lights on and turning
the music off and saying we need to talk
that's hard living less than
feeling like you can't breathe when your
spouse is in the room trying to avoid
that sunday afternoon dad because he's
just that hulking
presence that's hard too so at the end
of the day you're just
choosing your hard and i would rather
people choose to walk a little taller
and breathe a little deeper
instead of just looking down the barrel
of the next 15 20 years and going this
is just the way that
is right nothing breaks my heart more
than that statement i guess this is just
the way that is
yeah you don't have to be that way and
it's
it's 30 bucks it's 15 bucks a person you
don't have to leave your house
right come on so easy join us
and if you've got questions about
marriage you got questions about
anything relationships mental health
starting a business friends all of it
give us a shout
this is the ramsay show
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at ch ministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm christy wright and hosting with me
today is my good friend dr john deloney
and we're taking your calls
about life money relationships and time
management give us a call triple eight
eight two five
five two two five i also have a
challenge for you for those of you that
feel like you never have enough time
like we all feel all the time i wanna
give you
some tips that's going to get you back
24 hours
in your week i promise text
time finder to 33444
that's time finder to 33444
take the challenge and i promise you you
will get
24 hours back in your week and you can
do
whatever you want with that time all
right we're going to go to
sarah in klamath falls oregon where i
have spoken before hey sarah how
are you i'm good how are you good how
can john and i help today
oh thanks for taking my call my question
is what advice would you give
someone who loves their job but
recognizes that that job might not be
good for their family
what do you mean by that um so i'm a
wildland
firefighter and like i have
i've worked like 50 hours of overtime
this week i have two little kids
yeah y'all had a heck of a week huh yeah
wow so is it just
the amazing amount of hours and the
unpredictable schedule is that what you
mean in for in terms of
why it's not good for young kids yeah
primarily
yeah is this seasonal and i i don't mean
that
in a silly way but for the first
responders that i've worked with
and know personally there is a
fluidness or fluidity to their
home life meaning at any moment they can
get have to walk out the door
but there's also seasons where they're
home a lot right
and are there moments like i know
buddies who are police officers that
work the third shift and that stinks
because they're leaving for work at
midnight and getting off at seven but
also they get to take their kids to
school every morning so
are there trades like that you can make
or are you starting to feel
mortal and you're starting to feel i
don't want to make this bad all the time
yeah yeah so it is seasonal my winners
um are way more flexible which is
awesome
um i was able to yeah like you said take
my kids to school every morning
and see them in the evening and kind of
come and go as i please but
during fire season i'm pretty much
committed the whole summer
so here's here's one of the things i
want to suggest or
offer sarah and you can tell me if this
resonates with you or not but
um i love that john brought up the
seasonality
because there are a lot of careers a lot
of industries that have a seasonality to
it let's let's use a completely opposite
type of work
accountants accountants in the spring
are working
all the time in tax season right like
they don't see their kids a lot
and that's just the reality of the
season but they know actually use that
exact example in my book they actually
know at the end of that season when tax
season is over and everything's wrapped
up
there's going to be a lot more freedom
flexibility and time so there's this ebb
and flow to it and i think the thing
that you have to think about is
is that a seasonality that you're okay
with that you it's worth it to you
because you love that job
or you want something more stable and
predictable i'm going to go out on a
limb here sarah no pun intended but i'm
going to live
suggest that if you took this work to
begin with you're not the type of person
that wants this predictable nine to five
whatever you like this type of work but
but what i want to encourage you is and
this is what i really try to
um teach people in my book it is to take
the pressure off that you have to do
everything for an equal amount of time
you have to be
a perfect mom going to school every day
of the whole calendar year but instead
balance comes from doing the right
things at the right time so where you're
in this season the right thing right now
is to do exactly what you're doing and
then the right thing in the winter is to
take your kids to school and go on play
dates and have fun in the afternoon
but when you begin to realize it's not
that we're gonna do everything for an
equal time we're gonna do the right
things the right time
then when you allow yourself to be
present for those things when they're
happening
you're not only more proud of those
things because you're doing the right
things at the right time you're like
yeah i rocked it at work because i was
able to do this thing and make a huge
difference because this is what's right
right now in this season but you also
shake the guilt of feeling like you
should be doing anything other than that
and so if there wasn't a seasonality to
it to john's point and you just worked
50 hours a week and never saw your kids
for
years and years on end yeah that's a
different question but if it's like hey
this is the season for this this is the
season for what i do like an accountant
or like anyone else that has a really
hard season
and an easier season i think there might
be something in that that can set you
free
um to be present for that and not feel
so guilty if it's the work that you want
to do but you can tell me i mean if
if a more predictable schedule is
appealing to you that's a that's
that's an option for you too well i
i i love my job um and i think the
stress comes from my husband
he he hates me doing this job
and so it's that that added stress of
trying to
balance my marriage and knowing that he
doesn't want me doing this
yeah that's a that's a whole different
thing john's going to just jump
so to relieve you and of any guilt
what what chrissy just said is dead on
and
kids are incredibly resilient they need
stability and predictability
and honesty and so i see this with
parents who are getting deployed parents
who are entering tax season
in my home i looked on the calendar this
week i was hosting
the ramsey show three times um
i have a money marriage event i've got
chapters of a book
i i knew this week was gonna be wild and
my family's taking a quick vacation next
week
so we had a family meeting this week and
i said hey hank i'm not gonna be able to
go fishing josephine we're not gonna be
able to go out in the woods and play
baby dolls or whatever it is crazy
things she cooks up all the time
but here's the season and they get it
it's when i try to pretend that i'm just
being the same old dad that this week's
not been so
kids are resilient you have to be honest
with them and you gotta have some
predictability and they know hey we're
heading into fire season
we're gonna have this great adventure
what kills me
and more importantly your kids is when
there's a disagreement or
a couple who are roommates or couple who
are not on the same page and you use the
kids
as the excuse and i'd much rather you
face what i would consider a bigger
dragon which is sitting down with your
husband and him saying i'm
scared to death that you're going to go
to work and die or
i can't do my job if i've got to be a
full a a dad plus during these seasons
like those are more honest conversations
the kids if you're honest with them and
you're predictable are gonna be great
especially if they've got another parent
that's picking up that slack in those
off seasons
it's when you and your husband start
having that tension the kids are gonna
absorb that and that plus missing you
is gonna add a whole new layer of them
trying to solve for that gap for the
rest of their lives
and so you've got to sit down with your
husband and say we've got to have this
hard conversation
is he scared of you dying is he not like
your schedule because he's missing his
video game time what is it
um i don't think he's particularly
scared of me dying
but it's the schedule it's the fact that
he has to pick up the slack and
he has to take care of the kids 24 7 and
he doesn't get a you know any of free
time for himself
yeah that's an issue that you all need
to address sooner rather than later
that's what's really going on in your
question that's actually really your
question yeah
yeah that's what's really going on here
because i can't imagine how you could go
to work
guilt free in your busiest season sarah
knowing
not only is your heart at home with
leaving your kids of all that is
naturally goes into that being a mom
but also you know your husband's not
supportive that that
will eat away at you and so and so
getting on the same page you and your
spouse having those conversations maybe
it's
maybe it's with the counselors certainly
stay on the line and we'll give you a
ticket to the money and marriage event
tonight that dr john deloney and rachel
cruz are going to be leading they're
i'm sure there's going to be some
teaching and some content some tips that
you can
to give you a jump start to this
conversation
but that that piece of this is what
needs to be fixed
and so that's what i would look at i
mean the the
the trajectory here you know they they
say it's one degree and the car will
eventually turn all the way around the
trajectory
here is man this is
this is on a path towards that
frustration when he feels he's got to go
pick up the kids
the resentment you're helping somebody
and then you get that text from him and
you're frustrated that you feel like you
have a job that's got meaning
this is a recipe for resentment and
you've listened to me for two seconds
it's
really hard to come back from relational
resentment
it's just i mean you're really your
relationship's in ash and yes christy
we'll address this specifically tonight
sarah stay on the line we'll give you a
ticket to the money and marriage event
tonight with dr john deloney
and rachel cruz and for anyone else that
wants to get your ticket ramsey
solutions.com
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
if you're struggling to keep up with
payments you know what it's like to be
so scared and overwhelmed
that you can't think straight i have
been there
i remember i remember that feeling
the good news is you don't have to live
like that
when you pay off your debt as fast as
possible like we teach people to do you
will never
have that kind of stress in your life
again you can
do this and here's where you start
financial peace university millions of
people have taken this class and learned
how to pay off debt and take control of
their money
and you can stream all nine lessons
right now
or you can get some extra support by
going through the class with other
people
and the way that you get financial peace
university is with a ramsey
plus membership you can get rid of the
debt that's holding you back and end
this cycle of worry
and stress to start your free trial of
ramsay plus
just text trial to 33789
that's trial to 33789
if you're listening to this right now by
the way if you are a ramsey plus member
you get all kinds of extra other perks
like
getting to view the money and marriage
event tonight
for free those are the types of things
that we
give to our ramsey plus members text
trial to 33789 to start your free trial
today all right we're going to go to
bradley in utah hey bradley how's it
going
pretty good hey i have a quick question
for you
uh me and my wife are in our last
semester of college
and uh we have about twenty three
thousand dollars saved up
um and we were just wondering how what
we need to do with that money
what would be a good thing to do would
it be to keep it in the bank
or to invest it or put it into something
else
yeah so our let's walk through the baby
steps are do you have debt
no no debt very cool man awesome
okay do you have an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses
yeah well that the 23 000 that's uh a
year's worth of expenses
oh cool awesome okay cool and do you own
a home or are you planning to buy a home
uh we're renting right now but we plan
on buying one in
a few more years okay well cool well
here's what i would do
um i know that you don't have your
timeline totally nailed down
the timeline moves up for any reason
where you want to buy a home sooner then
what you'll want to do is just leave
that money in savings
part of it half of it obviously would be
your emergency fund the other half
could be going towards a down payment on
a house if it ends up being
you know further out uh where it's going
to be five years three years five years
seven years so it's going to be longer
you can certainly work with an
investment professional
um at ramseysolutions.com to just get
that invested where it's earning a
little bit more money than it would be
in a savings account but
the the whole point of savings is that
you have access to it it's not to earn
interest
and so if you think you'll be buying a
home in the next year or two
then just leave that money in savings
and then when a home comes available
certainly with the market being
crazy like it is right now you can kind
of keep an eye on that
and then when you're ready um to buy a
home you just continue to add to that
savings and that would be your down
payment does that make sense
yeah but in college in college your
number one
job is to invest in yourself and get out
of college debt free yes
and the number of students who have
something come their way
that last semester whether it's hey
someone out of the blue is going to call
you for a job interview
in some weird state but you got to fund
it to get there or your car is going to
fall apart
or they're going to jack your rent up
whatever the goal is to get out
debt-free so hang on yeah like chris
said hang on that money
don't overthink it don't overdo it your
job is just to get out
debt-free one of you is going to say hey
what about grad school whatever happens
your job is to get out debt-free and
then get into those baby steps yeah and
you're and you're doing it
you're so far ahead yeah man you're
doing it now the other thing that and
you make up a good
you make a good point john that i forgot
to mention when you're graduating
college
you are in a transitional stage in life
so whether that's what job you're going
to take or if you're going to buy a
house like
there's going to be a lot of things
variables that are at play and it's
always good to have that cash in the
bank and you're not talking
about a huge amount of money we're
talking about a very reasonable amount
of money
and just have that cash in the bank to
give you options get out debt free and
then whatever your next step is
that cash is going to help fund that
step but great job way to go
all right we're going to go to sarah in
indianapolis hey sarah how are you
hi i'm good how are you good how can
john and i help
yes so chrissy i am a long time follower
and fan
and actually met you last year at the
business boutique conference awesome
during the vip luncheon i
had asked you a question about like how
do you know when it's time to throw in
the towel
oh i remember a lot of advice i remember
that moment crying and i was there i was
crying we were all crying
it
well i took your advice um came back
redirected
my sales are like literally on fire this
year
i had to take a month off because i had
surgery um but
over the first six months i've grossed
over 30 000 which is
more than what i've ended last year you
are amazing
i'm at the point where i am ready to
hire help i do know that my time
you know is being spent way too much on
the business but how do i know
if i need to just hire some help to come
into my health
and help me a little bit here and there
versus actually taking the funds getting
the brick and mortar
and all of the expenses that then come
with
brick and mortar yeah so i i want you to
do something really simple really
practical
um to help you decide this and it's not
something we have time to do on this
call but you can do it on your own
and i'd be willing to bet you haven't
done it only because it's
kind of a pain to do it but i just want
you to compare
what the role would be and what it would
bring you so for example
hypothetically i would hire someone into
my business for 20 hours a week
they would do this type of work that
would give me back this much time and
make me this much money
or hypothetically i would hire someone
into my home
that would do this type of work that
would free up this much time which would
then free me to work on the business
that would then bring me this much money
you're just going to do kind of a
comparative
analysis and it's literally two columns
sarah like it's not complicated it's not
fancy
it's just comparing which one is more
beneficial to you and it may be
something
where you split the difference and you
say i'm going to bring someone in the
business 10 hours someone at home 10
hours
and then and then that's going to kind
of divide and conquer but i just really
want you to compare them because we can
think
oh my gosh like i'm drowning in
housework i need to have someone come
into the house which which may be true
but really just feels overwhelming when
it may be better spent
to hire someone into the business that
could actually bring in extra income
and and then you you know you get your
kids and you're able to kind of uh take
care of the house a little bit better
does that make sense
yeah it does because with the brick and
mortar you think oh it's out of the
house
now i won't have to be working you know
12 hours a day but then
are you really because i think with the
brick and mortar you still are like
if you're on vacation and the place
burns down well you have to figure out
how to get back home
you know and so it's like
is it really trading in stress and time
and
getting giving you more time back i
guess um
so yeah it's like john deloney said a
little bit ago it's not that it's not
hard it's just a different kind of hard
sarah stay on the line i want to give
you a ticket to our business boutique
event this fall i don't know if you have
a ticket if you do already you can go
ahead and gift that to someone but i'm
so stinking proud of you
you are rocking it and what a great
problem to have your business is taking
off
you need help i just want you to
literally take a notepad
a pin and write a couple columns like if
i hired someone
in the business what would they do and
what would that bring me
in time and in money and then if i hired
someone into my house to help me what
would that bring me
in time and then obviously potential
money assuming you're doing something
else
with that time that's now not spent in
the home so two columns
compare both options it may be something
that you pick one or the other and it
may be a little bit of both
but i think that's going to give you a
little bit more clarity because you're
going to have actual numbers
and not just a hunch an exhaustion to go
on because i tell people all the time
tired decisions are never good decisions
um but one other thing to consider is
when you figure out what this person is
going to do
be very clear on what the results you
want to achieve
be very clear on your job description as
we call it in entre leadership
key results area what are they going to
do
and define success for them and for you
whether you hire them in your home or in
your business and then you know
what you're running towards you know
what the expectations are how do you
how do you put a premium on your time
yeah like how do you do that like decide
i'm worth this much
an hour well we can talk about that
after the break i mean it's not it's not
a formula
it's it's it's a bunch of variables you
consider and as you consider these
variables together
you come up with a range we can but we
can that's a great idea we'll unpack
that after the break
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm christy wright joining me today is
dr john dolone we are taking your calls
about life
and money relationships and time
management
all the things give us a call triple
eight eight two five
five two two five if you want to
pre-order my new book that just launched
for pre-order on monday
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance you can get your copy at
ramseysolutions.com and when you do you
will also get the e-book in the
audiobook for free
and a ticket to my live event september
14th
that's take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance
i want to help you take back your time
am i allowed to tell people that it's
selling like bananas
ah it is we're surpassing our goals
which i'm so excited about this is a
pain point for people
hey and goals at ramsay are not goals no
they're
they are if you have goals then if you
work at ramsey they're tripled
and we don't shoot low for anything so
for you to be exceeding goals
is is way up there congrats
thank you thank you it's definitely a
team effort that's for sure and it just
shows what it is this is cool just say
it's awesome
it's awesome and it's such a pain point
because we never have enough time john
we i don't you don't none of us do and
so i want to help people with that so
uh before we went to the break you asked
about how you put a value
on your on your time here's right here
come from that so um
i come from a background which is if you
hire somebody it's because you're lazy
okay that feels extreme welcome to
christy how long do we know each other
so like if you if you
just figure it out and do it yourself
and
mow your own yard you fix your own car
you change your own oil and then what i
i began to hear a few years ago for
folks who were
getting into leadership who were running
their companies who were busy
who were moms who were dealing with all
of it is you've got to come up with
an hour of your like what is an hour of
your work time worth
and if it exceeds that you got to hire
somebody out to do that because your
time is so if you can
mow your yard it takes two hours to do
that and you think that you're
like if you do the math and you're worth
75 bucks an hour you need to pay
somebody because it costs 30 bucks
to mow your yard right um i never have
been able to rationalize in my head what
does that actually look like how would i
come up with a with a with an
hour amount for my for my time or if i'm
going to hire an employee right
right what's what's the right way to do
that i think i think it depends on
several i mean the way that you're
asking
okay let me back up when i teach women
to price themselves to price their
products and services through business
boutique for example in a business
environment uh we walk through several
you know variables so cost of goods sold
your your talent the quality of
materials the time it takes you you you
take all these variables
into consideration the industry you're
in and so on when you come up with a
range
what your competition is charging and so
on but what you're talking about is
different i actually use this
interesting example
in my uh goal planner i have content you
know monthly themed content throughout
and in the month focused on time which i
actually believe is this month for those
people that have the goal planner
i tell this story of this woman um on a
phone call whenever we were i was doing
research and she was telling me about
how
a doorknob broke in her house and um now
you could go down to
the local hardware store and get a
doorknob for maybe three to four dollars
like these are not expensive
things but she really wanted to
make it like like make a doorknob from
scratch
fix it make it something so she's like
googling and youtubing and she's getting
all the
the little little springs and all the
little parts and pieces whatever
and after about 30 hours
she makes this doorknob for like i don't
know a dollar 27.
and she was so proud of herself that she
saved
like two dollars right and like as she's
telling the story i'm going like
i feel like maybe she's missing but she
lost a thousand dollars of your soul
right right right but i think there's
something interesting and again not to
pick on older generations but from the
older generations um
certainly my mom's generation i know
matt's parents i see this in them
it's a do it yourself it's a
do-it-yourself generation they grew up
they didn't have as much
and so they're like no we're not going
to waste food my dad does not waste food
at the dinner table you better eat it or
you're
ungrateful um and because of that that
culture and that context and that even
world view that they grew up in that
experience that they had
it is harder for them to value their
time whereas matt and i it might be
easier
for us to pay someone to mow a lawn
because we're going well i could
pay someone this much money or i could
you know have the evenings with my kids
and you put it so for me and you're in a
position too like our grandparents
were in the great depression they didn't
they there wasn't a hundred percent they
don't have that
100 but even if they're out of that
right even like my dad has money but it
stays with you
still won't spend it yep um and so i
think it's interesting how that shapes
your world view but you have to ask
yourself it's it's again it's a
cost-benefit type of thing it's not just
well if i'm going to put 75 an hour on
me for example in your lawn example
then if i pay someone to mow the lawn at
30
it doesn't mean i have to go spend that
time making money
no i guess but it's but but what is the
value of time with my kids in the
evening or time you know whatever so oh
and i've also learned that
i used to do it to save that two dollars
that her story reminds me of me
i'm gonna spend a week doing a thing
that
should have taken five dollars in 30
minutes once i shifted it from
a scarcity mindset if i if i don't like
we need that five dollars here because
to you know what i like i like learning
hard things and i like figuring stuff
out where it's
a hobby totally then i love it and then
i can high-five myself but it's not an
identity anymore
right and it's not a cost-saving move
it's a this is a fun
project move and that's just a different
different way to approach it
all right we're going to go to brenda
and amarillo hey brenda how are you
hi i'm doing fine how are you today
great how can john and i help
okay i am high functioning
autistic okay
and i am extremely
talented in a number of
areas all right i paint
i sketch i design i draw and i cartoon
cool outstanding and they're great songs
awesome i
just don't know how to make my talents
work
for me okay what do you want to do which
one of those
not that you have to totally pick but is
there one of those that you enjoy more
than others that you want to really um
focus on
um i like music and i like my books
okay cool well i'm going to give you
some really simple advice brenda
and i think this is going to help you
make progress and this is the same
advice by the way i would give
any woman in your shoes this is not
different for you because you're high
functioning autistic this is just what
is a good step to take if you want to do
something
that you're not sure how to do but you
have talent there
and that is to spend time with people
that are doing
what you want to do we talked about this
earlier with ken coleman in his book the
proximity principle which we can send
you as well if you stay on the line
kelly will
send that to you but the idea is if you
spend time around people that are doing
what you want to do
you're going to learn so much about what
you need to do
and most people
okay i have spent time around people and
they say that my work should have been
published
long ago so are you asking how to
publish a book or
just in general how to make money at
your your talents
how to publish how to get my songs out
there
i am not good with computers okay
i took three years of it i was ready to
bounce them down the stairs
okay i
am i
have had compliments and actually
whenever i was early in my career or
trying to make my career
i met bob singer
he's the guy who did the sled stones the
jetsons yogi bear worked for hannibal
rare productions
cool and he gave me a cartoon
the um of the flintstones elephant
and it's standing on a cliff and it said
uh brenda would you like to be my
understudy here at the studio you see
i've got this gift to jump over
i did not know that that was an offer
wow oh wow
well here's the thing brenda whether
it's that
offer or something else you have the
potential
you have the talent you have the
opportunity
it might just be taking some very small
unimpressive steps and maybe that's
finding a high school student that can
do the computer side of things for you
getting you a blog or social media
publishing your work where you can start
to get exposure and eyeballs because
even if you publish you need someone to
sell
to sell to so creating a little bit of
an audience and certainly
online is a great way to do that and
they're in west texas you can
play a thousand different places play
your songs
you can self-publish there's a million
different things you can do stay on the
line let
i'm gonna have kelly sent you my book
business boutique as well that's gonna
show you step-by-step marketing that you
could do to get your work
out there and then watch how those small
steps begin to snowball
and it turns into that thing you want to
do but it might just be one small step
at a time i want to thank producers
james child associate producer kelly
daniel and my co-host dr john deloney
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker
just tell alexa google assistant or siri
to play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsay show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money i'm christy wright i'm a
business coach
author and speaker and i'm joined today
by dr john deloney
who is also the host of the doctor john
daloni show
and author of read that's a lot of words
author of redefining his
funny name dr john lots of
i don't know it's friday at 3 o'clock
that's what's going on uh we are taking
your calls
about your life your money your anxiety
your time management whatever you want
to talk about we are here for you
ability to pronounce names i'm gonna
practice after this
are you oh no triple h listen to this
america
christy wright i learned that in grad
school
triple eight call 825-5225
anything with your questions we are here
for you
john deloney nailed it has an event
tonight
has an event tonight called money and
marriage where he and rachel cruz
are going to be helping you in your
money and in your marriage it's a live
stream
a digital date night tonight at 7 30
central time you can go to ramsey
solutions.com
to get your ticket which brings me to a
question i have for you dr john doloni
i got a call i got a question on social
media
from kathy and kathy brooks asked me
this
she said how do i get my spouse on board
now we get this question
about business i get this question a lot
through business boutique women that are
starting side businesses home-based
businesses
small businesses how do i get my spouse
on board with my dream
uh we get this call all the time on the
ramsay show how do i get my spouse on
board with the plan
how do i get my spouse on board with the
baby steps whatever we just had a call
in the last hour how do i get my spouse
on board
with my career they're not supportive of
my career in that example
i want to hear from you i know it's a
super general question but do you have
certain
either questions or conversation
starters or like
here's where to start from here's how to
start and not make a mat out of the gate
here's how to start on like a
a really good footing for a hard
conversation
when you want something and they don't
want that thing i know it's a big
question but
in my head in counseling we talk about
the presenting issue
somebody comes to therapy somebody comes
to see a counselor in some sort of
crisis and says
i've got anxiety i can't get my heart
rate under control
i can't get myself out of bed i want to
fix that
and normally you back up or you begin to
unravel i pull those threads and you
realize
oh you talked to yourself in a certain
way and who told you that this was your
right so there's bigger things here well
what i often see in this situation
is somebody looks at a thing
my husband won't get on board with my
what i want to do with my job
or my on this show especially i want to
be debt
free and my husband says that's stupid
i'm not doing that
and they want to solve that issue and
that's not the issue right
so any time i've got a quote-unquote
issue in my house
i always want to go to what's the layer
beneath the layer
the issue below the issue yeah so it's
for instance
in my house my wife is clearly
if you listen to me for eight seconds
clearly she's the one
who is smarter and organized and on time
when i i'm a little bit of a human
hurricane but let's pretend
that she's the one so instead of coming
and saying hey
why won't you be on the dave ramsey play
it's ridiculous i want to get out of
debt
i would sit down in a not on the back
end of a fight
right where everybody's amped up
nobody's listening now we're just trying
to run
or try to fight and i would say i'm
terrified
that we are one flat tire away from not
being able to
feed our kid i'm one fight away at work
from getting laid off
and we got nothing and i don't know how
to say these words but i'm scared
and this feels like a way that we could
provide some margin in our life that i
could breathe that i want to show up
here and be present and i haven't
figured i would be present yet because i
can't breathe because
we owe 75 000 student loans and we just
keep buying and buying and buying
and when i come to the table with
vulnerability first and you've got to
remember that that word
literally means for an animal like a
think of a porcupine to roll over and
expose its belt you can be hurt
and i've heard husbands get the courage
to say the words i'm scared and their
wives are like are you some kind of wimp
right so it happens and vice versa but
that is the way it's that is the issue
the issue is i'm terrified
the issue is i don't want my kid to grow
up in the situation i grew up in
whatever that becomes the thing yeah and
then we can talk about the vehicle by
which we get out of this thing
which for instance is the dave ramsey
it's it it works every time yeah
right so that becomes like
i can imagine in your world and i'm i'm
you know i have never talked about this
but if somebody just if my wife came to
me and said i'm doing the side business
and i want to do this and you're gonna
have to figure out how to
it's almost an attack versus i want i've
got this passion i want to explore this
value there's a part of me that has
never been explored professionally and
created creatively
how could we make this work together oh
my gosh i want to be all in on that
right right and i think that's probably
what happens in the
the uh relationships within the
conversations more more often than not
where one person is scared to
approach it maybe you have a more
dominant personality or or whatever
and so they actually they don't come in
with guns blazing if i want to start the
side business usually it's like
scared to bring it up at all and i think
that you know putting some language to
that i love how you talked about fears
because if i can look back on any of
any of matt and i's discussions about
things that we didn't agree on
initially or we had to work through it
and it was not an easy decision or
whatever the thing was where i thought
it should be this and he thought it
should be this
and we've had plenty of those like every
you know marriage does
when we start to say what are you afraid
of what does this represent to you
then it's actually not about the
decision at all whether we do this or
that spend this money or that but
whatever it is it's like this represents
this to me
right this makes me scared that this is
going to happen and if you can begin to
address well here's how
we could do this and that wouldn't
happen or here's how we could do this
and this is not what that is
then it solves it like you said at the
deeper issue and it's amazing how many
of our conflicts have been resolved by
asking those questions around
this was what this represents to me or
this is what my fears are around this
another thing i would say just to give
some language to the people
listening right now that may feel like
they don't have as much of a voice in
the marriage or
they're the ones that they feel like i'm
scared to bring this up sometimes
your spouse isn't supportive not because
they don't want to be but because you
have not
made it clear that this is important to
you and so just those words
this is important to me right whether
it's this business this money plan
whatever
it's not to say that that's going to be
all of a sudden that's just an ace you
know that's just the trump card that
also they're going to be on board
but it should if they are a good spouse
if they are you know
love you and value they should lean in
right if if matt comes to me and says
this is important to me i am all ears
i'm i'm a different level of engaged
and paying attention and trying to find
how we can solution this thing that is
important to the person i love most
line at the end of an hour and a half
discussion aft an hour after everybody
usually goes to bed
and somebody's crying and somebody's
yelling that
yelled this is important to me is not
helpful no that is a
i want to go out to breakfast i want to
go to dinner and talk about something
that's really important to me
right and here's the hard truth of these
conversations
you have to have an or what statement i
want
to have another kid i want to get out of
debt
you better have in your back pocket or
what like are you gonna leave
is that was that what you're really
gonna do or are you gonna be in this
marriage no matter what you've got to be
prepared for that or what statement
that's hard it's good this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text and
six gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over 70
a month by switching to pure top just go
to feartalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
so
[Music]
do you feel like you don't have enough
time i do a lot of times
john you feel like you don't have enough
time i feel like
you're asking me a pointed question we
all
struggle with this idea of having enough
time for all the things that you want to
do
time is finite you only get 24 hours in
a day
but i've got a challenge for you to help
you actually get 24 hours back in your
week
you can text time finder to three three
four four four that's time finder
two three three four four four take the
challenge i give you a different tip
every day for seven days
that will help you get back truly 24
hours
in your week all right we're going to go
to
selinda in duluth minnesota hey selinda
how are you
i'm doing fine how are you good how can
john and i help today
i was just wondering how do you know
when is a good time
to sell a business well
tell me what's going on tell me what
your business is and why you want to
sell
well i have an e-commerce business and
i've heard
two rumors that e-commerce businesses
are selling for a higher price right now
because of
the boom and then also within inflation
and stuff i'm afraid that maybe the
business will start going down
on those values so kind of
wondering if that's a good reason to
consider
selling or not okay well how long have
you had this business
for three years okay what's your net
profit
your annual um
about two hundred and fifty thousand
okay
do you like this job or
depends on the day did you create this
business with the intention of selling
it
yes that that is the intention okay
um it's kind of to help help fund the
retirement someday when we sell it
gotcha do you have offers on the table
uh no no and we haven't listed or
anything it's just
where my husband and i are considering
whether we should or not
yeah how old are you i'm 39.
well here's what uh here's what's
interesting about selling your business
cylinder and this is something that you
can think about for yourself i certainly
can't tell you
but there's two major factors in
selling your business timing is is not
one of them in my opinion
i mean it is a factor but it's not a
major factor the major factors would be
the financial
right like what are you going to make
off of this sale
the other one that i would consider a
major factor when you're a business
owner this is your baby you built this
thing up
is the emotional aspect of it how you
will feel when it's gone
how you will feel when someone else is
running it you may feel incredible
relief like yes oh my gosh i can't wait
and you may be like
kind of sad i wasn't quite ready yet i
jumped the gun because i
i thought the timing was good or
whatever there's there's an aspect of
looking at timing that is wise
but i never want people to make a major
decision like that and that's a major
decision
um with a scarcity mindset like you
can't sell it in three years
or you can't sell it in five years
hypothetically if you do it right the
value should only go up
and you can sell it for more later
so i'm not opposed to you selling it now
i just don't think you have to sell it
now
i don't want you to make the decision to
sell it now out of fear
because you think that you're not going
to get as much or more later because i
don't think that's true
does that make sense
yes it does and i think a lot of what
sparked it was
the market's good now but it might not
be later yeah
i i don't i don't enjoy it and it is
giving us a very good income
yeah it is i mean that's a great income
here's the thing so linda if you
if you are not um if there's not a time
sensitive reason to sell it now
in your personal life or your business
life i would not let a scarcity
mindset about the market drive you to
make a major decision like that
because you can sell it later you're
only going to grow it
e-commerce is not going anywhere it's
only growing as well
and so i think it's one of those things
that it's not never
it's just not right now um if you came
to me and you said hey here's all the
reasons for
i'm ready to retire i'm tired of the
business i don't enjoy it
i want out and the market's good cool
that's a totally different question
but if you're having fun and it's
bringing in a good income and the only
reason you're thinking about it is
because of the market
i would say hold i'd say stay in it keep
that awesome income
keep growing it and then when you're
ready personally
as a family you're ready to retire
you're ready to let go of it fully
then you think about selling it and
you're still going to make a
great great income on the sale of that
business i hope that's
that helps but you're in a great
position and way to go for growing this
business
that's awesome to a net profit of 250 i
mean that's incredible
that's incredible well done all right
we've got emily in grand rapids hey
emily how are you
hi i'm will christie how are you good
how can john and i help today
um short short version sorry i'm kind of
nervous
no you're all right we're nervous too
we're nervous too go ahead
okay cool and i was just listening to
you down on youtube so this is even
weirder
so okay so my husband and i are in baby
steps
four and six we don't have kids um we've
been
in our career path for more than ten
years and we both hate it
and want to do something else and an
opportunity has come for us
to move across the country to take a
completely different job and i'm
wondering if
this is a fun opportunity and adventure
that we should jump on or if it's just
coalition impulses then we should be
more
thoughtful about picking up and leaving
what's the opportunity
um so my brother lives in west virginia
and he works for a natural gas company
on the pipeline and he can get my
brother
a job down there so my brother's been
wanting us to move to west virginia for
the last year and
now a job came up and he's like when are
you moving are you going to fight when
you move what are you going to do
so now it's like we'd have a job
should should we do it or is it just too
impulsive to
up and leave and quit our jobs and i've
never lived more than an hour from my
hometown and
i'm all nervous but also this sounds
like a good push to do something else
and if we hate it we can always move
back
if you hate it you're in the jobs you
are in right now you hate what do you do
now
yeah i am a clinical microbiologist
so i grow fungus and tuberculosis
and herpes and anything else that comes
out of you or off of you or
that's crazy you're really smart
yeah no that is really cool so i
here here's the rationale my wife and i
just used we
lived in texas every day of our life and
then we got this opportunity to come
work at an extraordinary world-class
university
here in nashville and we use the exact
same thing that you just said
what's it if we come out here and it's a
bust and it's a disaster
we can just move back and we both find
something else we both have skills and
we were fortunate that we didn't hate
where we were you've got that added
pressure
you've got the right spirit behind this
which is if we go to west virginia and
it's a disaster
you can grow herpes i don't know what
that means you can grow fungus right
surely you can there's other places you
can grow that so
um you've got a set of transferable
skills you've got a million different
things you can do
in in christie's right you hate where
you are now
and so you've got a great job you've got
family connections when you get there if
it's not going to be a toxic
nonsensical environment here's the thing
i'm all
for it and so do the wild thing
the sensible crazy thing if that makes
sense and
i love your heart behind it this isn't a
forever thing give yourself two to three
to four years
go for it and then if it's a disaster
move here's the thing about you
it won't be a disaster it'll be great
and there'll be parts about that are
hard
and there'll be parts about it that you
never experienced and you loved and
you'll be lonely and you'll find new
friends and all that will be challenging
and exciting
it's just going to be is that what you
want to keep doing right yeah yeah we
put so much
existential pressure on these things
that just doesn't need to be there
right well and and it seems like all the
variables you should consider
line up to move you don't have kids so
you're not worrying about schools you
hate your life you hate your jobs
so we're not leaving something we love
we're moving closer to family
and you've got a job waiting on you even
if that job was a stepping stone job
like hey we're going to do it we may not
love it either but it's going to get us
closer to family
and be a new adventure and then we find
something new we grow
fungus in the new place like that's
that's cool that's exciting i
yeah and your baby steps four and six
like yeah i say do it i don't think it's
your responsibility
do it you're leaving a job you hate do
it do it do it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
auto insurance companies love to play
the game where they see just how high
they can
jack up your rates for no reason real
fun right
good news is it's not hard to beat them
at their own game
all you have to do is check up on your
policy every year or two to make sure
you're getting the best price for your
coverage
that's it and what's even easier not to
mention free
is that you can hire one of our endorsed
local providers
or elp insurance agents to do this for
you
they are independent agents who shop to
find you the best coverage free of
charge
they don't work for one insurance
company meaning they have the freedom to
shop
as many policies as it takes to find the
one that's right for you
don't sit back while your insurance
company raises your rates for no reason
text auto to 33789 and put a trusted elp
agent on your
on your team that's auto to 33789
all right we're going to go to gina in
phoenix arizona hey gina how are you
hi christy and dr dalony thanks for
taking my call sir how can we help
well i have been a stay-at-home mom for
the last
uh five or so years and i just got a job
offer today
and so i'm wondering not only
you know opening this new chapter of my
life but as far as
financially we're gonna have a second
income so i'm kind of wondering
you know it's opening this whole new
world to us so just
maybe some direction sure well that's
exciting i'm assuming you're excited
about this
yes absolutely awesome what are you
going to be doing
i will be a personal trainer and a
nutrition coach which is
finally what i want to do oh well
congratulations that is super exciting
thank you
well we we guide people when it comes to
money um on the baby steps and so do you
are you familiar with the baby steps
yes actually we are debt-free except for
the house um
so we're looking to invest and kind of
move down that route and also there's
things that
now we have the opportunity to save for
like a bigger car
and a roof on our house and sure the
practical things
sure well here's what's so great so now
when you do your monthly budget
you're going to incorporate this new
income into it and so what that means is
you're definitely going to have some
more money to play on
and just enjoy as you should for your
work and the work from staying home and
the work that you now have
out in this new job but also you're just
going to be able to get a little bit
more aggressive
with your goals um at baby steps four
five and six so when you're investing if
you're not already investing fifteen
percent you wanna invest fifteen percent
total of your of your household income
your take home
and then you're also going to want to
put that money into a college fund if
you haven't already started that have
you started that yet
we have yeah okay cool so you continue
to contribute to that and then the rest
is just put it towards your house and so
you can pay off your home early you can
put extra mortgage payments
you can um uh you know if you've got one
big lump sum you want to put on it you
can if not you can just
pay more each month on your mortgage and
so really
what this is doing gina is it's just get
it giving you
a bigger shovel towards your goals so
your goals are the same
you're on baby steps four five and six
you're definitely going to have a little
bit more freedom
in your budget but as you incorporate
that in i think you'll find
uh that you're making more traction on
those baby steps even faster and
having fun in the process does that make
sense yeah
awesome go ahead uh hey gina can i throw
some unsolicited advice your way
yes so one of the things i see
couples who one of them is returning to
the workforce and
everybody's excited because they do the
math
what they often gets lost is the rhythm
of
a household the rhythm of their
relationship and so i want you guys to
build in on your calendar
at least a weekly check-in
no kids no calendar no budgets
just a talking with each other for an
hour or whatever that looks
look each other and i say how are we
doing how are we how's work
and i want you to be able to say whoa
it's i'm excited to be back in the
workforce it is
way more tiring than i thought or i'm
three weeks in
and you are not helping like you like
you said you were going to
and he's allowed to say yeah the
business gut is about to get busy we may
need to make some other
but i want you all to create a rhythm
where you are checking in with each
other because this is going to affect
more than your money and i see couples
all times
just look at that bottom line they high
five each other we're gonna get new cars
the new roof we're gonna pay our house
off in two years
and then suddenly their marriage is on
life support 18 months later because
they didn't anticipate the extra shift
in the relationship does that make sense
oh absolutely and we've already kind of
had the conversation you know
eased into it a little as far as um you
know you're gonna have to be doing a
little bit more
and he's totally on board so okay so
that that can be a
great primer but you're gonna have to be
specific
and when things aren't being done then
you're gonna have to be vulnerable and
say it and he's gonna have to say the
words i'm sorry and
and all so be specific like that you
have to pick up some slack i got it
man that's that's a recipe for flying by
each other in the night right so
setups very direct here's what i need
you to do here's some help i need here
some support i need and we're going to
work on this together
let's talk about this john because this
is a really interesting point and you i
always refer to this because it was so
helpful for me
you talk about when you're communicating
with your spouse or anyone but
specifically in marriage
uh visualize what something looks like i
use this all the time like hey what do
you want to do on saturday let's have
fun yeah and we agree and then and then
our idea of fun is not the same so you
say visualize it like in pictures
i think this could be even really
helpful for this because gina in your
example when you say
you're going to have to pick up a little
more i think it would be a good exercise
for you to define what that means
are there specific things you expect
your husband to do and need him to do
and want him to do
and certain things you want to do um and
then get on the same when y'all have
these conversations and check-ins
have him speak into that as well like
what does this look like because i think
that
um he could he may hear that and he may
do a couple things and he's like well
i did it twice i did a little bit more
yeah like one time remember that was so
great that one time i did that one thing
and he feels like he's hit the mark i
mean i'm not trying to be funny but he
feels like he hit the mark
and you're resentful because you're
doing all the same stuff you did before
because y'all were used to a rhythm and
roles that you had
and now that you're going back to work
there has to be very
clear like here's what i would like to
see happen these are the things
i want to still do these are the things
i would like for you to do here's the
things we do together so like um
i travel gina and and so one of the
things that i've talked about before is
hey matt like i'm so grateful that you
were able to hold down the four and all
the things while i'm gone
one of the things that is like really
kind of frustrating to me is if i come
home
and there's a house is a total wreck yes
because it's like a calming
talk in my house coming home to a wreck
i know it don't have to be spotless like
we don't have grocery stocks but like if
you could just not have it be a wreck
that would be awesome
and then he'll say to me like hey these
are the things that i really hate doing
can they just be your things and i'm
like cool yeah they could and you just
both speak into expectations with
unbelievable specificity speak into that
and be very clear and then i think what
you'll find gina is
um the conflicts the resentment the
disagreements
are much much less because you had those
conversations but congratulations
congratulations on your new job
congratulations on being
just a champion the last five years home
with your kids that is the
uh i can't even imagine how hard that
season was that is a thankless job
of the diapers and dishes and it just
all happens the next day and so you have
done that successfully and now you're in
this new season and we're just we're
super excited for you so have those
conversations
do the budget and i think it'll be great
here's how here's two examples from my
house one
if in the past shiloh said hey i need
you to help with the dishes and i'll say
got him sure
monday goes by i'm thinking help with
the dishes
there's some day listen there's still a
day full of cups there's nobody out of
cups in this house they're right there
and for her she cannot close her eyes at
night oh if there's still cups out
this isn't still dishes in the sink i'm
so urgent
if i ask matt to do something i'm i
don't understand why it hasn't happened
in the next three seconds he's like
chill out like give me a minute i'm like
i'm sorry i meant
right now yeah if they if i can't see
them
over the top of the sink we got plenty
of space
i open the drawer there's still spoons
there there is no need for dishes
and if there's spoons in right and so
it's it's about that specificity
so clear and then here's the other thing
so this comes a lot with intimacy like
when you're first dating you're first
married you just you're just
infatuated with each other you know
you're all over each other
and then i you meet with couples two
five ten years in
and it feels less romantic to have to
schedule intimacy on the counter
similarly yet very different now when my
wife is coming home from being out of
town she will text and say
four hour warning then she will text two
hour warning
i will be home in one hour and that is
the
i need this place clean i know you've
turned this into a bachelor pad
you've got four hours but it's her
helping me it would be great if she just
showed up and it was all clean it's not
gonna happen so she helps
me out help me help you this is help me
help you the ramsay show
[Music]
our scripture of the day is first
thessalonians 5
18. give thanks in all circumstances
for this is god's will for you in christ
jesus
and our quote is from sheryl stanberg
you will be defined
not just by what you achieve but by how
you survive
all right i am hosting today with dr
john deloney one more segment if you
want to give us a call triple eight
eight two five five two two five we are
taking
your calls about life and money
wanna remind you don john deloney and
rachel cruz have an event tonight money
and marriage you can get your tickets
at ramseysolutions.com it is a live
stream event tonight at 7
30 central time and my new book take
back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance is
available
for pre-sale and you can get your copy
at ramseysolutions.com
all right blinds.com 100 satisfaction
guarantee means that even if you
mismeasure
or pick the wrong color they'll remake
your blinds for free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promo codes
they run every month you'll save even
more use the promo code ramsey to get
the best deal
rules and restrictions apply today's
question comes from pam in new jersey
my two sisters and i will eventually
inherit a sizable estate that includes
not only investments but real estate
one sister and i do not see eye to eye
on most areas especially money
how do i avoid confrontation or deal
with high
emotions when it comes to this sort of
inheritance
john deloney this is your specialty
avoid confrontation well that seems like
that's not possible
you're not going to avoid confrontation
and you're not going to deal
avoid high emotions um you're gonna have
to be highly intentional
way way upstream so you say eventually
inherit
and so these questions are always hard
because i want to know a little bit more
information i want to know
is your the person you're inheriting
this from able to sit down
and dictate what's going to happen now
are they
incapacitated and suddenly are having to
come to terms with the fact that we're
about to inherit this stuff
there's two things you can do here
number one you can go with your sister
my brother did this we went out one
night and we spent a long night together
just saying
was i was leaving texas and i looked at
him he lives in the same town as my
parents
and said i'm i'm out i'm the i'm the
older brother here i want to make sure
we're on the same page
and he was so thoughtful and had so much
thought out that i hadn't planned for
and
i mean it was just such a gift to hear
what amazing man my little brother was
he's a little brother he's in his like
you know he's old now um
but we sat down and had a heart-to-heart
about it and
um so i would recommend pam just so you
can sleep at night
to go out and say we're gonna inherit
this we know that we do money
differently
how are we gonna approach this here's
what this is going to look like um
assuming that doesn't work then you're
going to need to get a third party
whether that's an attorney
you're going to need to sit down and
decide hey can we look at this will so
we know who's going to be the
the um the person who's the executor and
all do as much of that upstream as you
can
you are right once somebody dies and
there are checks and zeros in real
estate
it is a free-for-all it's emotional it's
a disaster
so the more the stuff you can handle
upstream the better yeah the solution
to so many of the things we have been
talking about today and questions that
we've gotten
on the ramsay show is to talk about it
intentionality yeah talk about it so
many people
just try to avoid talking about things
and if you would talk about it now
granted you need to talk about the right
way with the right heart and ask the
right questions and
and and find the common ground but man
avoiding
avoiding confrontation avoiding high
emotions avoiding conflict avoiding
communication is not the way to do it
and if you have this conversation
and it is a train wreck that's
information that's
data right now you know this is not
going to be this is not going to be
amicable
this is not going to be a simple
solution or we're not going to be on the
same page
here now i've got to go invest in a
lawyer now i've got to go invest
in fill in the blank right yeah i got to
go do some other things but until then
it's just this cloud of anxiety and
anxiousness and frustration and anger
and that's just a mess yeah yeah that's
a good point you know how to proceed
even if it goes bad you know how to
proceed all right let's go to melanie in
san francisco hey melanie how are you
i'm doing great how are you guys good
how come
john and i helped today well
i've been debating on calling for a long
time i just
got on to dave ramsey probably two
months ago from one of my
agents in my brokerage that i work for
and
i am 28 years old i have two kids under
two
and i've been married for five years
we've been together for eight
and i just kind of hit a spot where
i found no motivation i don't feel like
i'm worth a lot
like i'm just a mom and i know that
sounds so loaded
i struggle with anxiety a lot and i've
been struggling lately with self-doubt
and
being a new realtor with nothing under
my belt it's
hard to get out there to get your first
listing or get your first buyer
and i lately i've been doing this before
i got my license in october and i had my
son a week later so i've been really
doing this for
maybe seven months like all the time
and i just don't know if
if it's right for me i don't know i go
back to
this is what i worked so hard for i went
to school i paid this off it's all
ready but i just it's the self-doubt
that gets me it's my husband is
i left him to death and i'll spend the
rest of my life defending him but
he just has no goals he has no
aspirations
he's just happy and content and i'm
mom and he's dad he goes to work he
comes home and
yeah i do everything and i hate to say
that but
uh i don't know how do i go about
getting my husband on the same page
about getting debt free because i
i i guess i'm just looking for insight
yeah melanie first of all i just it's
funny even on the break
john and i were talking and i was
talking about just in matt and i's
journey we had
two kids a year and a half apart and i
remember that year
i remember that year melanie like it
about nothing has ever done
yes yes it is it it about broke us
and and and i hear it in your voice my
husband and i are at right
now and i talked to him the other day i
i broke
and i said i'm not happy something's
something
i'm not happy and i i i was such a fun
outgoing social butterfly i would talk
to anybody and now
i'm just i'd rather just stay home you
know with my kids and
yeah i just i just i don't know maybe
i'm wrong for calling i don't know
no you're not at all i'm so glad you
called i want i want john to take this
this is his specialty but i just want to
encourage you one thing
because i was literally just in your
shoes a few years ago and i know
everybody says it melanie but it's true
this is a season this is where you are
this is not who you are your season does
not define you
you are in a season of little kids that
are
absolutely consuming you are exhausted
that is where you are that is not who
you are and i
promise you i promise you it will
get easier john can can take this from
the anxiety and the self-doubt
angle but i'm just saying with the
little kids like i hear it in your voice
i was you and i swear as i sit here
today
it does get easier you are still that
fun girl
and you will go out and be fun again you
are just
in a season that is exhausting and i
promise you it will get easier
i can take all of the clinical expertise
on planet earth
and none of that matters like hearing
from a mom
who's just been there my husband and i
also too
i i don't like talking about because i
don't want anybody to feel pity for me
because i don't want any pity
we lost our son at 41 weeks
during delivery uh four years ago
and since that moment happened we
we just kind of coexist that's what it
feels like to me i love him to death and
he is my husband yes but
it's we just co-exist at this point and
i just i need to i want to save my
marriage and i want to get debt free and
buy a house and do all these things but
that's right it's very difficult so
you're taking on
the world right now and it's like your
boat is sinking
and you're also thinking about a
mortgage and you're thinking about where
your kids are going to go to college and
right now you've got to get to shore
okay you are exhausted
and that's focus number one so i want
you to
get some time with your husband y'all
get away
and find somebody to come sit with you
with your little kids
you can get 48 hours and i want you just
to be with each other
this this christie's right this
conversation who we're going to become
and what we're going to be and all that
your body's going to become yours again
your heart's going to become yours again
your mind will become yours again
and then you will have a season where
you have solid ground you can work on
your marriage that's not today
today is about survival
you got this and we'll be praying for
you melanie stay on the line kelly will
give you a ticket tonight if you want to
view it tonight or anytime later just to
encourage you and give you that kick
start to have that conversation want to
thank producer james charles
kelly daniel hey this is the associate
producer and phone screener for the
ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
you